(airy swooshing)
(deep boom)
(snappy click)
- I really, really,
really, really didn't get
in my career on like charisma
or cuteness or by accident.
The marriage between sales and branding
is very real on the internet.
And most people are one or the other.
(slow jazzy electronic music)
- Yeah!
- [Gary] You got your perspective.
I just wanna be happy.
Don't you wanna be happy?
(slow-beating bluesy piano music)
- Hey everybody, it's Gary Vaynerchuk
back with an audio experience episode.
This one's super-fun for me.
As many of you know
I've been building up my text community,
212-931-5731 for the kids at home.
And did a fun little thing
where I kind of blasted
out to the community.
I get into a very Santa
Clause mode once in a while,
where I just wanna do random stuff.
I think surprise and delight, serendipity,
chances, such a exciting part of life.
And so one day, I don't
even recall where I was,
probably I, no question,
was flying or doing something
that wasn't in the office
'cause I wouldn't have time for it.
And I said, "Somebody's gonna get flown,
"or in this case trained,
up to the office,
and be on the podcast, and
we'll see what happens."
And that is exactly what's happened here.
And so we are here,
Dustin had a lot of
technical difficulties,
so that was a fun
7-minute awkward situation
where I had to take out
some business fires,
and I really appreciate, seriously,
you sitting there with
your friends nice and calm.
So let's get into the episode.
So the real punchline was questions.
I see you're very prepared.
I see paper, which excites me.
- [Theresa] Yes. Yeah.
- Why don't you tell the Vayner Nation
who you are and how this all happened
from your perspective.
- I'd be happy too.
- [Gary] Tell me that story. I'm excited.
- Well, I'm Theresa Stover,
and with me here I have Larry
Davis, Shaun Fitzpatrick,
and my husband Rick Stover.
And, I guess, back in October
Shaun had let me know -
I'm a big podcast fan,
I have a kid that goes to Pittsburgh,
so I've got 4- or 5-hour drives often -
so he turned me on to you.
I started listening, started following,
started doing everything.
And I
tweeted
that
I am
a female owner of a company
that was started by my father
who was an immigrant,
son of an immigrant, excuse me,
we have multi-generational impact.
So things that I thought kind of related
to what you talk a lot about,
and I was lucky enough to get picked.
However, I didn't know for about 48 hours.
- Really?
- Because, yes, we had three kids,
we had a crazy weekend with sports.
And my oldest daughter, who's at Pitt',
kept trying to call me to tell me.
She didn't want to do it over text,
and I was blowin' her off, hard.
- And so for everybody who's listening,
so I sent it out on text,
the community's quite large.
I had told everybody to use a hashtag,
tell me their story.
Theresa's story is very good,
and much like most of you,
you know a lot about me.
So every reply on Twitter was quite good.
I'm gonna help you buy the Jets,
let's talk about sports cars,
like every book button is getting pushed.
And to be very honest,
and I'll continue to do surprise
and delight my whole life,
it is all serendipity.
It is just wild serendipity.
Of course something catches
your eye to make the decision,
but it's much more in the subconscious.
I'm not clicking accounts,
or there's no data being thrown at it.
It is like me making a subjective call.
And the way I do it is
I reply to that person,
'cause it's done on Twitter.
So what's easy for me when I do this
is I reply to that person,
cc my team on it,
and then go on my merry way.
And one day, randomly,
that person shows up,
and that's what was happening.
So I reply to you on Twitter,
but you're so crazy you don't see it.
Your daughter sees it,
but she wants to deliver the news,
so here you are so busy
you're not even answering
your own daughter,
which by the way, I love and respect.
- [Theresa] Well, we
were at a football game
for my son.
- You won me over immediately.
Like the fact that you're at that place,
where like if she's not
saying 911 or emergency
you're like, "Yeah, I'll
catch up with her later."
I just love that to begin with.
But keep going.
- Well so we were at
my son's football game,
and she kept calling.
And Rick is like, "I gotta get the call."
And I'm like, "Put the phone
down, we're here to watch Eli."
And he gets it. She tells--
- [Gary] Eli Manning is your son?
(soft chuckling)
- No, Eli Stover,
unfortunately, yeah (laughter).
- [Gary] Shout out Eli.
Keep going (laughter).
So anyhow we get the news.
And then, of course,
I completely ignore Eli's game,
and look at my phone
as I'd hoped not to do.
But, it was for a very
good and exciting reason.
- So you actually picked up the phone,
and she tells you,
and then you go look at your phone?
- [Theresa] Well no, he did.
- Oh he told you?
(soft muttering)
- He didn't.
He's like, "You won the contest."
And was like, "What are you
talking about? Oh my gosh."
So then, of course, and I
had gotten a million tweets
and all kinds of stuff.
So my phone had blown up,
but I have all of my
notifications turned off
certain weekends and things.
- Smart.
- So a day or so later I figured it out,
and of course, now we're here.
- That's awesome.
When was it?
- It was, like, October.
Yeah, October. So--
- So here we are.
So what do you want to do with this time?
- Well, what I'd love to do
is tell a little bit about
my families business.
- [Gary] Please.
- The reason Larry's here, Shaun,
of course, he's the whole
reason why we're all here,
and, of course, he's my nephew and Rick.
Anyhow, I'd love to tell a
little bit about the company,
and then open up to questions
for you. If that's okay?
- [Gary] I'm here for you.
- Okay, great.
So I mentioned Larry's
our Marketing Director.
He took over,
and started working with
us about six months ago.
He has a background in retail,
and has spent his entire
career in marketing.
He's made an immediate impact
since joining the company, which is great.
- [Gary] And what kind of company is it?
- We are a home and improvement company.
So exterior home improvement, roofing,
siding, windows, doors, gutters,
and we also do bath.
- To the end consumer?
- Yes.
- Understood.
- Shaun joined the company
two years ago in sales.
He's risen from new kid,
selling over a million in his first year,
to our number two salesperson,
overall selling 1.7 million in 2019.
So he's killing it.
- And he is a salesperson,
since you're going to consumer,
is doing what?
- Closing deals, so there's 30 of us.
- That are coming from
your outbound calling?
- And inbound because of
the reputation we have.
How many calls did we take?
- So your brand, right,
you're third generation it sounds like.
- [Shaun] Forty years in business.
- None-the-less 49 years.
You have a brand locally.
So your inbound inquiries
need to be converted?
- Yeah.
- Among other things.
- Are you cold outreaching
- Yes.
- in sales or is it more?
- [Shaun] No, we go in and it's all.
- So the website or the phone call,
or whatever other top of the
funnel behavior you're doing,
comes and then you're converting inquiry
or questions into potential business.
- [Shaun] Yep.
- Understood.
- So my dad started the
company a million years ago,
as we said 1980, but a
little bit about him.
- Can 1980 not be a million years ago?
(laughter)
'Cause I'm old enough to
remember 1980 pretty clearly.
Shout out to Dover, NJ,
and the kindergarten school
that I was in in 1980.
Go ahead.
- So the interesting thing about him,
which I think is part of why we got here,
is he was a fifth child of
an Irish-American family.
His generation was the first
generation to be born here.
Of his family.
So his dad was an engineer,
came here because there was no work.
- Right.
So
he
went to high school,
graduated,
and was married at 19, was in college,
and had myself and my sister
by the time he was 21.
And was doing roofing and
siding work on the side.
- Old school shit.
- [Theresa] Yes. And realized that
maybe college wasn't what he needed to do,
he needed to provide for his family.
- [Gary] I like him already.
- So he started subcontracting,
ended up starting his own business.
- [Gary] That's Cool.
- So
part of why
the whole reason why
the company is where it is today
is because my dad is a man of integrity.
All of the decisions he
made through the years
were made because he wanted to,
he named the company after
himself and reputation.
- [Gary] I know the game.
- Yes. I can't say enough
great things about him.
He was involved until about 11 years ago
when Rick and I bought out his company.
- Is your dad alive?
- [Theresa] He is. He's retired.
- Is he listening to
this podcast right now?
- He will be.
- [Gary] Good.
- When I send it to him .
- [Gary] What's his name?
- Pete Fitzpatrick.
- Pete, great fuckin' job.
All right let's keep going.
- So one thing that my dad
instinctively knew how to do was
to provide great customer service
along with all the other
great things that he did.
Even as a young child I knew that,
and I felt connected to the business.
I was the oldest.
I was always at his side.
I would be there,
he would take me to
afternoon appointments,
I was under the desk,
I would try to sneak in.
If he said I can't go to an appointment,
I'd try to sneak into
the back of his truck.
I'd always get into trouble.
So I've always felt really
connected to the business,
however, I didn't join the business,
except for small roles I did in college,
which I gave out fliers,
I would call back his appointments,
do things like that.
But I didn't actually join
the business full fledged
until just under four years ago.
- [Gary] Interesting.
- Yes. I came on to help in recruiting.
Now Rick, on the other hand, my husband,
got involved 18 years ago,
and he left a job in banking,
took the leap to the family business.
And he's worked in various roles,
working his way up to GM,
until we bought the business 11 years ago.
- [Gary] Very Cool. I
understand everything so far.
- Yeah, so fast forward to now.
We have 110 employees.
We do over 30 million in sales
from all the work we talked about.
All of our work has a lifetime warranty,
we take great pride in the
company and our culture.
- This is just for my continued context.
This is the service provider
of these things, right?
You don't sell any branded items.
You don't have a gutter with
your companies name on it.
Your the service provider.
- [Theresa] Yeah.
- I understand. Keep going.
And how regional is it?
Like, it's Delaware?
- [Theresa] Delaware valley.
- Delaware valley.
- We cover four states, four
counties in Pensylvania,
most of Delaware, part of Maryland,
part of Jersey.
- [Gary] I understand.
- So my goal is to get
your help on our marketing.
Our overall marketing strategy,
that we are using,
is a traditional strategy:
print, direct mail,
commercials, Google Adwords,
we recently dipped our toe
into the Facebook pool last month.
Prior to that, and well,
in October Shaun and I
started using your philosophy,
which is we started really trying
to ramp up our social media.
So we're now on Facebook, Instagram,
Twitter, LinkedIn, YouTube.
We were already on Facebook and YouTube.
- But your on it in a more thoughtful,
like, you're taking it more seriously.
- [Theresa] I guess they took
a shot at it a few years back.
- Happens all the time.
- [Theresa] And didn't see any results,
didn't think it was working,
and abandoned it.
- Makes sense.
- [Theresa] So now we're
really giving it a try.
- Why?
- Well a couple reasons,
and this is really where I wanna
have these guys talk as well.
- [Gary] Please.
- I really feel like,
well our customer base
tends to skew a little bit older.
- [Gary] Makes sense.
- So especially for our bath products.
- I also think because
we didn't see any results
it was abandoned.
- So everyone saw it as
like a fun, nice to have,
but not necessary.
- [Gary] I understand.
- So
we've,
of course,
seen a huge increase
in engagement since we started.
It's gone great,
but what we're here to find out is--
- How do you connect it to ROI?
- Right. Since there's no way
to track anything but engagement--
- Well that's not true,
since the strategy was set
up to only track engagement,
you're struggling with the notion
of does it lead to sales.
- Well I'm not necessarily.
- Because you intuitively believe it
because you're the son of a father
who built a business on word of mouth,
and social is predicated
on the same nuances.
- [Theresa] Right.
- Same nuances, not
the same. Same nuances.
- Very easy for pops' back in the day,
(trilling tongue) "Hello, is this,"
what was his name again?
- [Theresa] Pete.
- Pete. I apologize.
"Hello, hello is this you Pete?
"Yeah, I'm Mr. Thompson
"on Delaware street in Delaware.
"My friend Rick told me you're
awesome. Can you work here?"
Very easy for him to
know word or mouth works.
When you don't have a human
on the other side of
that lead that came in,
you don't know if that was print
or direct mail or radio or television
or social or Google AdWords
unless you strategize to do that.
It's very easy for you
to post something right now on Facebook,
you can create a separate
Google phone number,
a Google voice number.
- [Shaun] We do those things.
- The ability to track it, is--
- [Theresa] Well we
don't do it for social.
- Understood. If you did every
piece of content Facebook,
and it had a phone
number on it at the end,
not even throwing the right hook,
just having the phone number there.
You would then be able to see the data
on which phone numbers
came in from that number,
and which one of those
converted into his 1.7 in sales.
It's actually shockingly exciting to me.
Most people, to your point,
and by the way 99.7% of businesses,
let alone small businesses,
and by the way for everybody listening,
30's insane, it's a real fuckin' business.
But I'm talkin' corporate talk.
Small businesses don't set it
up to be able to measure it.
- So you're saying that we.
- It's the most trackable thing.
'Cause it's happening on the internet.
You have to have a,
if you are an organization
that is desperate
to see results on every
dollar in the short term,
which at some level everybody is,
it all depends on how much money you are,
you have the luxury of thinking long term.
So I'm sure, back to the history
of this business by listening,
you're okay with it truly paying out
for real three years from now.
'Cause you're not looking
to flip it tomorrow, right?
So yeah, I mean I just
gave you the direct example
of how easy it is to measure everything.
You could have a separate phone number
for YouTube, Twitter, Facebook,
like, it's so measurable
it's actually uncomfortable.
(whole room muttering)
- We do do that.
What's hard, for us numbers
guys to wrap around our brain,
is the specific posts that are really,
well the jab so-to-speak,
and the jabs are not ads obviously.
- The good news is the jabs,
and I appreciate you using my terminology,
I'm flattered,
in theory can be so inexpensive.
They cost less than the stamps
you do on your direct mail.
So it depends on how you're quantifying
the cost against your jabs.
The other thing that is very challenging
is for you guys to really
get to the numbers game,
you have to turn off
the other advertising,
and suffocate advertising
to see what's working and what's not.
My belief is that you're
making assumptions
on things you've done historically,
and you're putting the new stuff
through a scrutiny that you haven't done
for the other stuff
'cause it's been accepted.
- Yeah.
- [Rick] All the media
is pretty well measured.
We have a phone number for
every newspaper we're in.
Every different newspaper.
So every newspaper's a
different phone number,
and our paid ads on Facebook
have specific phone numbers and specific--
- I see. So you're more having a scrutiny
around the organic content.
- [Rick] The organic. I guess
the question I wrestle with is
Theresa's content is hugely
engaging, so we get lots of--
- Her, the human or what she makes?
- [Theresa] What I'm posting.
- You, the human?
- [Rick] So we're getting lots of jobs,
we're getting lots of likes and shares.
- Are you getting qualitative feedback?
Like, are you getting comments?
- On some, yeah.
- On some.
- Okay.
- [Rick] But not necessarily
related to roofing, right?
So roofing is a pretty tough subject
to get social engagement around.
It's like, you can post videos
about mold growing on your roof,
and it's not gonna
generate a lot of response.
But that's the key issue in roofing.
- Yeah, and to your point,
like, I'd rather get
zero comments and likes,
and get two customers from a video I make
about a moldy roof on Facebook,
than to do a ton of things
that get all of the comments in the world,
and lead to nothing.
To your point, also, all
that stuff that's being said,
and all of that engagement
is actually probably leading to business.
It just might be hidden,
and that's what you're trying to tackle.
- [Shaun] That's the big thing,
I think, for us in general.
- Can I give you a great recommendation
that works for this scenario,
all the time?
- [Rick] Please.
- Why don't you guys make a decision
on costs on the jabs and organic.
Make one number, financially,
that appeases the numbers guys,
and appeases the jabs and gray people,
and move on your merry way.
The things I've always done
for brand in long term,
if I decide I'm gonna
spend 47 thousand on it,
and I need zero ROI on return.
I've already won because
I'm not having debates
with the people that are
looking at the numbers.
We both all collectively agreed
that we're gonna make this 47
thousand dollar investment,
and we're not gonna be
emotional about that.
And as long as we stay
within how we quantify that,
away we go, and thus you're spending
no mind time to debate.
You've made an investment in brand.
It could be zero,
I'm unemotional about that,
but what it does is it puts it in a frame
where you don't have to worry
about the organic ROI of it.
In a world where you may have people
that believe in brand
or the subtleties of it,
or believe intuitively it's working
versus ones that want
to put a quantifiable number against it.
And if it's 25 thousand, as long as like.
If you just take your
overall marketing mix,
and decide to take five
points out for branding,
and that becomes the budget.
Then there's no tension in the system,
and everyone can go on their merry way.
Unless the gray people want
a lot more money than
you're willing to allocate.
- And I think maybe even measuring,
so the posts that Theresa does
don't really cost us
anything, other than her time.
- My time.
- Which is the best fucking
business of all time.
I would argue then, if that's true,
why are we even debating
it if the cost is zero?
- [Larry] Part of it is
maybe could we do it better,
so it does more tie into our business?
Is there ways to engage people
in what we do, not just--
- [Theresa] Tie our
traditional with the social.
- Forget about traditional.
I think it's more about what
you're trying to accomplish.
Right? I think it's less passion
about traditional or digital.
I think it's more about how do we.
There's many questions here.
One, do you want to do that,
or are you enjoying?
This is now a human question,
let alone an executive question,
you've gotta mold the
human and the executive
in a family business.
- Well, I'm enjoying doing it.
My concern is we do, our
customers do skew older,
and they're not gonna be around forever.
And I am concerned that
as the millennials,
they're becoming more of the homeowners,
my concern is we're not engaging them
the same way we are the boomer generation.
And I think this is a great way
to potentially accomplish
something that way.
I don't know.
- I would say
it probably has nuances of both.
What I would argue is that,
first of all Facebook is more effective,
right now, for me, with 55 to 75
than direct mail and newspaper
for my dads business,
and most of the businesses that
are SMBs that I care about.
So, A, The greatest thing
you should definitely do.
There's a lot of
conversations going on here.
Let's break 'em down.
The A/B test against
your newspaper strategy
is really interesting to me.
Here's why Facebook, in theory,
if you have the creative capabilities,
will beat newspaper
in the dynamic that we just talked out.
No matter how low the
cost of that newspaper ad,
in a hundred different places,
with the phone number is.
Facebook's advantage is two things.
We spent about a billion in media,
so this is coming from that context.
And we look at it.
When we work with big brands
we're still going local as hell, right?
What you definitely need to do,
if you're doing that much print,
is test the same exact
demo against newspaper.
If that newspaper ad is
costing you 800, 1200 dollars,
running 8 to 1200 dollars
against a piece of.
The reason Facebook always wins,
when both are done perfect,
is that in Cherryhill, NJ
I can make a reference
to the Giants and the Jets and the Eagles,
and that can hit three demos,
where on Facebook at $140
each against those fan bases.
Where as in print you'll
have to pick one of them.
It's the creative flexibility of Facebook.
And then my general opinion
that there's more consumption,
actually seeing it,
versus the print ad on page 142.
That to me is probably
the most interesting.
If I bought the business,
the marketing dollar A/B test,
and by-the-way,
though I think things
skew this way at cost.
It's not about is one
better than the other,
I just care about what something costs.
My favorite ad to buy in the
worlds is a television spot,
it's called the superbowl,
costs 6 billion dollars,
we bought three of them
for clients this year.
I'm very excited about
the three superbowl spots.
That one really excites me
because that's very measurable
for this organization.
So that's just one random thing.
'Cause it does skew older, and by-the-way,
a video of how-to as the ad
versus the print picture.
I know for a fact, that
if you built a machine
that got really good
at local Facebook ads,
it would grow your business.
Having the capability
of creating the content
at a low enough cost is very real.
There's unlimited $15 an hour creators
that would much rather have it,
even at a boring roofing company,
would much rather make videos
than work somewhere
else not making videos.
'Cause they're creative.
The entire ecosystem of
20, 18, to 30 right now
wants to be creative.
And so that's one thing to debate.
The cost of your creative,
lowering it by going
minimum wage in Delaware.
What's Delaware's minimum wage?
- [Larry] Twelve bucks, (mumbles).
- There's a lot of
12-year-olds, excuse me.
Child labor is a great, no.
There's a lot of people
who are so fortunate
that they can afford to,
or so hungry to live their passion,
to work making videos on roofs.
They just exist.
So there's a lot on that.
As far as the.
If you became me, if you became me,
which who I am right now is I have a lot
of young people fans of me.
What would still happen if
you had 5 million friends
on Instagram and Facebook,
you as a collective,
would try to understand
what the ROI of that
is for your business.
And the reality is,
is that
at scale,
I think you doing you,
the way I'm hearing so far,
is more like salt and
pepper not the steak.
- [Theresa] Okay.
- There'll be some nice nuances.
If you notice the cadence of my questions.
If you like it, I'm already happy
because then you'll do it
with a different vigor that
will lead to good stuff.
It will.
But to drive the business
you need a scalable model
to take advantage of these platforms.
Not to rely on a personal brand
whose not going direct at the.
I'll give you an example.
My content, now, leads to less business
for Vayner Media,
than my content for wine library lead
when I'm a hundred, trillion times bigger.
Why? Because in 2008, when
I was making a wine video
it was so direct to the business I was in,
that is lead to business.
Where as now 99% of my audience
is not Vayner Media clientele.
Got it?
- [Theresa] Yes. Yeah.
- Now, do I believe that you're gonna
inspire some other female entrepreneur
in Delaware on a post?
Yes, I do.
And do I feel like on next Thursday,
if she needs a new roof
or whatever else you're selling, bathroom.
That you came into consideration?
Yes, I do.
There will be business.
But if we're talking about scalable,
A, by the time you get
to a size as big as me,
that's real time and work and talent,
and B, I don't want you to miss out
on the actual opportunity in social,
which is some of the stuff I lead to
on the newspaper A/B test
that I just talked about.
- [Rick] So advertising is paramount
to where you see the application here.
- [Gary] Yeah. If I was the
fifth family member to join,
or teammate, I would say,
hey, I love your guys' spirit,
but I'd be okay if we did no organic,
and we ran paid against everything.
I would rather you run paid
against female entrepreneurs in Delaware,
against your content for $100
to amplify top of the funnel, and brand,
than to just leave it at organic.
- [Theresa] Okay.
- Mainly because the
ads are so under priced.
'Cause they're gonna get more expensive.
Facebook was uncomfortably
a good deal five years ago.
Uncomfortably.
It's starting to get to where Google is,
which is get appropriately priced.
I built on Google Adwords.
I bought every wine word.
I spent five cents a click.
- [Theresa] Well so that
was one of the questions,
we did wanna find out from you is--
- [Larry] That's 1980's.
- That's right you know.
- What platforms you would
suggest for a business
like ours?
- LinkedIn.
- [Gary] Your company
should be doing 10
pieces of content a day,
on LinkedIn, that is how-to.
LinkedIn.
- And again, content versus
paid advertising. I mean I--
- No, no, that's funny.
LinkedIn is actually a
very organic platform.
So LinkedIn is kind of wild.
It's one of these one places
where you can have no account,
like you probably have now,
post and actually people will see it.
But somebody might see it in St. Louis.
LinkedIn's ad products
are a little expensive,
but I like that you can target things.
You can target specific businesses.
You could look at who
is using your product
and have like a feel.
There might be a major company
only a mile from you guys,
and all the employees live
in the surrounding suburbs.
So there's a lot of strategy.
I'll give you one.
You could target Campbell's
Soups employees, right?
Big company in Camden, not too far,
sounds like it's in your demo.
And then the video is, like,
hey do you work at Campbell's Soup?
That alone has already got you in the mix.
That's the flexibility of social,
that print and radio don't have.
You're stuck to one
creative in the old world.
The game for this,
is the volume of contextual
creative at scale.
- Well we really need to, like,
those kind of ads,
you're not looking to do,
Hey $99 for a month for a new bath.
- You know what's funny?
I wouldn't be scared to play A/B.
And, by the way, if
you're cheeky about it,
and you have fun with it,
and it's a little less douchey,
I think you can really get away with it.
- I think their idea, from
the immeasurability aspect,
is I've watched your stuff forever,
and my initial argument is
sometimes people don't call the number
that you put on Facebook, right?
So the measurability, we don't know
that they're talking to their.
They're seeing our stuff,
and then they're talking
to their neighbor,
and then they're calling
through our website.
- Measuring brand versus sales
is the forever challenge.
When I see this scenario
where there's all good intent,
which is already, thank god.
You guys are on third
and fourth, fifth space.
I think you have a real
conversation around what I said.
I think if you have a
sales marketing bucket,
and a brand marketing bucket,
everybody's gonna be much happier.
If you guys agree to a
set number of dollars to,
we don't need.
Like, I doubt that the two guys behind you
don't believe in brand.
- [Theresa] Well we have a whole
branding department.
- Of course.
So what needs to happen
is don't blend the lines.
You make one core budget,
and you are cruising.
I've seen it a million times.
I've seen the most
contentious mom and daughter,
father and son,
family business,
small businesses,
executives, the most contentious scenarios
where I literally laid this out.
And literally a week later I get an email,
like, you saved our life.
We would argue all day long,
and now it's just 18
thousand for the year.
Carroll's pumped,
she's gonna spend it however the fuck.
If I'm the quant' and money and math guys,
I say that the art or brand people,
like, go put on black I don't give a fuck.
It's like I do my T&E budget at Vayner,
once I set how much you have
for travel and expenses,
take a fuckin' rocket ship.
I don't give a fuck.
You have all year to spend this.
You spend it.
You wanna take a train?
Did you take the Acela?
Did you take the, I don't give a fuck.
I don't want to judge you along the way.
Here's the macro-budget.
Go. I don't need to micro-manage you.
So I think that could really work.
- Yeah, makes sense.
- What questions do you
have, Larry and Rick?
- [Rick] So I just wanted to get back
to the degree to which the posts,
whether they're paid or organic.
- Only organic on TikTok and LinkedIn
at this exact moment in time.
- [Rick] Okay.
- Four years ago Facebook
organic? Hell yes.
- [Rick] Yes.
- Four years ago organic
Instagram? Hell yes.
Here's how they all start.
Once they hit organic is a dream.
But you can't control
where it goes, right?
And, if you have a narrow business,
then the ad product comes
out and it's a dream.
'Cause it's a market place,
and you bid it up,
and it's cheap as fuck.
Then that becomes properly priced,
and then it becomes overpriced,
and it never becomes as overpriced
as print, radio and television
'cause they set floors
based on their margin.
Market places are fair.
It's supply and demand.
But that's how the market goes.
Early is organic,
non-controllable where you go
if you're narrow.
But if you're just building macro-brand,
great for me, I want everybody.
Too under priced ad product.
That's where Instagram
stories are right now.
You wanna get younger,
and you wanna convert sales.
You guys should run a ungodly amount
of Instagram story ads.
Instagram story.
The main feed Instagram product
is getting close to being properly priced.
The story ad's, where you can swipe up
and land on the website.
Great for the guys behind you
because they're gonna see the lead gen.
And great for you guys because
it's super under priced.
Three dollar CPM's in Delaware.
Opening line of the video.
Hey, I just did it a couple
of hours ago in my office,
hey LA, hey.
Like contextual creative.
- [Theresa] Okay.
- [Rick] So keep it contextual.
- Always.
- [Rick] Always (mumbles).
- Always. It's why this is all happening.
The reason, if I were with you guys,
and we went through Penn' Station now
to go back to Delaware,
and an 82-year-old man
would ask for a selfie,
and a 13-year-old girl
and an African-American,
and a Latino, and a white,
is because I'm contextual
across all platforms.
I'm cool to 12-year-old girls on TikTok,
and I'm cool for 64-year-old
executives on LinkedIn.
Why? 'Cause I put different content out.
It's still me. I'm not making it up.
I just know what to talk about
to the audience because
that's why they would be interested.
By just starting the video as,
hey are you a Campbell's employee?
And they are because you used
the targeting on LinkedIn,
you've already got a prayer.
Go drive and film it in front of
that nice, new Campbell's building,
and your already even more contextual
'cause they'll see the visual.
It's all context.
This is contextual,
contextual warfare.
Not content warfare.
Content is what everybody focuses on.
The nuance under that is
contextual content at scale.
You need to invest in
making a lot of content.
- [Rick] Was that content
is king and context is GOD.
Did I read that sir?
- That's right (laughter).
I appreciate that.
And when you put those two together,
and when you have a business result,
you're off to the races.
- Did you have more?
- [Rick] I think that's
- I have a couple quick things. Videos.
- And real quick, culture, right?
So, like, when Joe Flacco retires,
you make a head nod to Delaware football.
Like, things.
Things.
Right?
- [Rick] It's very good that you do that.
I know a lot of stuff (laughter).
- [Rick] I like that. That's very good.
- Videos.
How important do you you think they are
versus pictures, or is
that different on every?
- You can make a 6 second Vine,
it's the same way I think about length.
Creative is the variable of success.
I make videos that are
fucking 2 hours long,
and people watch them.
I have 8-hour vlogs on
YouTube people watch.
And then there's videos I put out
that are 39 seconds
and they don't do well.
'cause it wasn't good enough.
So the length or the format is irrelevant.
Meaning video does extremely well,
we all know that people enjoy it.
But there's a lot of
people that wanna read it.
Or pictures, like, they could all work.
That has more to do with you,
then, it's not the format,
it's the ability of one to
communicate on the format.
- Okay.
- Okay, did you have any questions?
- I guess, personally, so I'm.
- [Gary] You've almost
watched too much content.
You already know all
the answers (chuckling).
- Yeah. Well, no, so for me,
so I'm in the situation,
kind of like what you
were in with your dad,
I'm doing our hardest job,
I'm 25, putting in a lot of hours,
and just trying to absorb.
That's why I'm here.
I'm absorbing everything.
And I'm really lucky that they're willing
to listen to me a lot,
and go back and forth with me.
- [Gary] That's huge.
- What do you think the type of stuff
I should be working on?
From somebody who's in
a business like this.
- My intuition, is the quicker you can get
from ideology to practicality,
the better it's gonna be.
I think the thing that
really made me successful,
that I always worry about
when people watch me,
and that are in similar situations,
is it always came.
Everything I talk about comes
from actual business results.
Right?
And so the vulnerability,
without knowing anything about you,
is when you're seeing
what I'm talkin' about.
I talk about branding and marketing.
I talk about building
Nike, not a sales team.
So when you see that,
and you start framing up my model.
When you go enter the real world,
I don't talk as much about
operations and sales,
which I equally do.
To me they're more commoditized
than building brand.
So my worry is, you come in,
and you come in with ideology.
And they're like, that's cute,
but what the fuck does
that mean for our business?
I know how to articulate that
to what it means in 12
or 24 months for real,
and show indicators.
My dad was the hardest of all.
He was an immigrant that was scared
to spend anything on anything.
He, luckily too, was
willing to give me a shot.
I had to fuckin' deliver.
So I mixed sales and branding.
Now, it sounds like you're
a really good salesman,
use that as leverage.
You promise them that you're
gonna do 2.1 next year,
and because of that,
give me another 30
thousand to do marketing.
You know what I mean?
- [Shaun] Yeah.
- That. Practicality.
- Do you see anything around the bend?
Like, obviously we know
social media's not going away,
but it's morphed from Facebook
to LinkedIn into whatever.
- [Gary] Are you doing any radio?
- No, we do TV, but not radio.
- [Gary] You do remnant television?
- No, we.
- [Gary] Like cable TV.
- [Larry] Broadcast news mostly.
- Oh I love that.
That's great.
That excites me,
but I'm telling you, get into the.
You leave here, look at
each other and be like,
that was nice, he was nice, that was good.
Contextual, creative, scale.
If you're spending TV budget,
you can't imagine what
you're opportunity is.
Once you realize what that TV product is
versus YouTube and Facebook video,
when you make contextual creative.
So this is very simple, business terms.
Make it simple.
If you're spending a thousand dollars
to amplify that commercial,
and you spend a thousand
dollars to make that commercial,
let's just play.
That commercial's vanilla
to the person on the other side.
You had to be broad.
You had to.
- [Larry] I'm in it though.
- You're actually in it?
- [Theresa] Oh I'm in it too (chuckling).
- Okay, well,
- We're competing.
- so now I'm excited because
you guys are attractive.
So now I know why it's converting.
No, but honestly, ready for this?
Literally, the life I
just lived, literally,
if you started the video with
Wilmington, listen to us. Right?
Philly, Harrisburg,
Cherryhill, Morristown, NJ,
we've been in the.
Like, when you get into that, it kills.
And when you realize that Facebook video
and YouTube video
and soon-to-be pre-roll on OTT platforms
where you can buy it, like a stock market.
I'm so happy right now,
I think you can tell by my excitement,
you are wasting real money on television.
Not because it's not working,
'cause you're like, no, Gary, you're wrong
we're getting these sales.
I'm like, that's fine.
Just like you would say to him,
that's a cute ideology.
I would say to you, that's cute.
Now, let me show you what you can do
with that 80 thousand bucks.
Where you'll pour it, back
to the analogy I said,
that thousand dollars is getting you
a certain amount of
results on the media spend.
You spend 2 thousand and make it happen.
I know that, that same thousand
on YouTube and Facebook would be better.
And that the content that you made
might cost you 2 thousand
'cause you made four videos at $500
instead of one at a thousand.
But I know the results would play
because you made it contextual,
and it was seen more.
- [Larry] On the videos, quality, I mean,
can you shoot 'em on an iPhone?
- Yep.
- [Shaun] Yeah, you don't need.
- You do know that there's
a YouTube pre-roll product
that's based on people's search, right?
You know that we can run
a pre-roll YouTube video
of somebody who's gonna watch
an Eagle's highlight on YouTube,
but the pre-roll is you guys
because you know they live in the area,
and they searched roof.
They searched renovating my bathroom.
- [Larry] I don't think
we've dabbled in that.
- [Theresa] No.
(soft murmuring)
- I promise you, I know
you guys very well enough,
I knew you were gonna like that brother.
You know why?
Because it's mixing sales and branding.
- [Rick] I could put the phone number on
for that particular Cherryhill.
- I promise you this,
and this is a good thing
to say to all four of you,
I really, really, really, really
didn't get to this point in my career on,
like, charisma or cuteness or by accident.
The marriage between sales
and branding, is very real
on the internet.
And most people are one or the other.
- [Rick] How do you mean, one
or the other? One sales or--
- You're either all about sales,
or you're all about brand.
- [Shaun] That's our
industry right now too.
- That's the world brother.
- [Shaun] We talked about it.
- [Larry] Our whole
industry is all about sales.
- [Shaun] Yeah, it so transactional.
- Good news.
Any small business, that sells something,
is all about sales.
That's why they stay small.
(soft chuckling)
- [Larry] I like it.
- It's very real.
And I say that coming
from a small business.
I built a business from 3 to 65 million
with no money.
None.
- [Larry] We spend a little
bit more (murmuring).
- You clearly do (laughter).
My first year budget
was 18 thousand dollars
for the year.
And I did it in five years
because I know what happens
when you marry brand and marketing,
and sales and marketing.
My great fortune
was that the internet just happened.
And so the price of
email and Google search
was so zero that I milked
the fuck out of it.
I learned that.
That got into pattern recognition.
That's why I invested
in Facebook and Twitter
and Tumblr, 'cause I knew
it was email and search
all over again in a new form.
But this time I got smart,
and invested in the
companies not just milked it.
And that's why I am who I am now.
That's why I'm never wrong.
I don't talk until it's been proven.
I'm not guessing on TikTok.
There's a billion fucking users.
May not sell roofs,
but what you need to
always be prepared for is,
maybe the way you make content on TikTok
becomes the way you content, you know?
More importantly, I always
get worried in a good way,
that's a slang term for interested,
when it's super young.
Because when it's 12, 13, 14,
you suck in more
grandparents than you think.
That's why I was so right about Facebook.
What I knew about Facebook in 2007,
when everybody thought
it was a college thing,
was, wait a minute these people
are posting their photos on there,
and their parents and grandparents
want to see their photos.
So just phycology.
- Last question I had, sorry,
and you've probably answered this already.
But, again, so when
we're running ads though
they should be about us,
and our products and what we sell,
but you need to try and make them
hit the person you're truly talking to
by making it interesting,
or specificity (trails off).
- Who do you like in
American football? If at all.
- We're Eagles fans.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Eagles?
You wearing an Eagles jersey
in the beginning of the video,
and running it on Facebook
against Eagle fans
that live in Delaware.
The visual already sold you more product.
Money in the bank.
And if you're a sellout,
because you're just about
business and fuck football,
and the next video you
wear a Giant's jersey.
Respect (laughter).
Context at scale.
What nobody understands,
this is not about spending
more media dollars,
this is about spending more money
on content creation,
to create the context,
to lower the cost of transaction
because you made it relevant.
The internet lets you do that.
Television, print and radio didn't,
which is why people didn't think that way.
Got it?
We couldn't afford it.
I ran it all too.
I couldn't afford six different
direct mail creatives.
You made one, 'cause it was expensive,
and then you went to all the zip codes.
Facebook lets you do it,
Instagram lets you do it,
YouTube lets you do it.
The big one, and this is why
it's so important to you,
but I want you to get good at this
because we're only five years away
from Hulu and Amazon
Fire Stick and Netflix
and the new television
doing programmatic, contextual buying.
I can run a commercial
in Amazon Fire Stick
based on somebody who
bought gutter equipment,
when they're watching
Friends on Amazon Fire Stick,
and live in Delaware.
Guys I'm telling you.
This is not a joke.
This is real-ass-shit.
But it's the marriage of the four of you.
Got it?
- Yeah.
- Do we have anything
else before we wrap up?
I did wanna say one thing.
You always give everyone a
hard time for not listening.
We have been listening,
we've been reading your books.
We started doing exactly what you said.
So I wanted you to know
that people do listen.
I know that,
and I appreciate that,
and more importantly I really appreciate
the four of you because this
is going to be one of the
best pieces of content
I've ever put out.
Because the framework
of what your dynamic is,
is actually probably the single
most important conversation
of meaningful small
businesses in America today.
You guys are in the exact crossroads
that millions of people are.
And just watching the four
of you in this meeting,
it excites me.
Because, you have to understand,
your world is far more my truth
than almost anything.
The Sasha Group agency I have,
that's the place to actually work with
for everybody who's listening.
Because that's what I did.
I took something small
and made it bigger with,
not Chase and Budweiser budgets.
And I know exactly how to do it.
- [Shaun] Awesome (mumbles).
- Yeah, and it's practical.
It's business.
LinkedIn organic's gonna work for you,
but Facebook, I'm tellin' you guys.
You target 57-year-olds
in Delaware Valley,
and you make 113 videos
on your iPhone,
and you have a fun day.
You're gonna have fun.
And then when you open up the kimono,
and you don't wanna
wear the Giants jersey,
but Paul in accounting is a Giants fan,
and we throw him in it.
It will work.
- [Theresa] Glenn.
- [Larry] Glenn, yeah.
- Glen, good news, you're
in (hearty laughter).
All right, I gotta get outta here.
Thank you guys.
Thank you everybody who's
listening on the podcast.
Listen to this four times
if you want a small business
doing 1 to 50 million dollars a year.
It is THE unlock.
And Theresa, thanks for being here.